wait are you Chris my sister's told me
all about you
Chris he's no threat to the PSA let's do
it are you right wait no wait when
you're back in the game I'm gonna see ya
do it you let me know
cha cha cha that was me testing the idea
actually won't let me see the cookie all
right watch out okay I've got I have a
[ __ ] knife I have nine bullets
speaking of noisy Spoony I'm going to
Australia when uh three weeks oh [ __ ] my
battery is low if it's controller oh
there's still people here let me I also
don't have a cord but it hasn't gave me
a warning it I need a spring water she
shoot us both fine
Miami super gonna be oh my god I'm on
balance I'm out of ammo
yeah me too well I hope he's cool with
me knifing his ankle that's ex who's
still here Pete Rob Rob's probably still
here get a little Rob he'll never let us
down
no John Lucas
oh yeah his computer sorry me it's okay
you cover me
I got a text the same
I have to find ammo I actually can't do
anything without ammo
Blake today's just a lot of technical
people what kind of game allows this to
happen I have no [ __ ] ammo I have
nothing oh you shoot a lot in this game
do you want me to go in here have no
ammo caught it all right cool
all right ten bullets here we go oh I'm
gonna stir it here we go oh I don't get
those bullets all right I got a turret
and [ __ ] in the boot remember we got a
jump on to him when we stun him uh
I am gonna do this entire thing with
like two bullets
Oh
no I don't want any points
I have to punch this man to death
give me your bullet like the need to
narrate what I'm doing so I feel like
I'm far from you I dude I I'm on this
balcony okay I am knifing you and I'm
not doing a great job I have like no
bullet hey what's a red oh he's near
though he's done oh [ __ ] wait sherry can
jump - yeah yeah yeah oh you're right
here all right according to new don't
kill me I need out
oh but he's done I'm working on it
god damnit [ __ ] your controller dead no
I'm setting the charges
oh it's fin member him uh babyface
assassin been alright actually a bullet
oh he's [ __ ] do something I'm not near
him hold on damn it why they're just I
got it I got it
oh [ __ ] them keep that right out of your
stupid head and stab you with it I did
it
haha oh [ __ ] kind of bullets again
obviously Oh always needs more time
that's all have you been me yeah good
message yeah Jan been hopefully they're
around oh I don't know I like I keep my
roller Oh Finn got one of the anti-air
thanks
I don't want any more points I could've
sworn I was charging my thing all day oh
yeah we're supposed to be doing that
thank you
or no maybe Jake and sherry Oh Oh No
okay see this red diamond we got to go
up there and he's [ __ ] up I don't know
I think we're smell be worried about the
anti-aircraft gun oh I'm doing it wrong
then
I see people and I want to kill them I
do see the little red thing on my map
maybe I should just yeah that's the good
Mikey yeah I can come in hey okay
there's a no that's not a door I can
open I haven't seen you in a while
all right on my way okay yeah come to
the blue marker at the doors here okay
but also okay oh it's Finn hey open the
door
yeah he blew it go go this should kill
us
here's Nivens and okay all right we're
doing okay here I don't have a lot of
bullets either but at least they're
dropping him pretty op yeah but it's
just a weird thing for a game that like
I just jump you know I just bud you
jumped over my head Oh Finn took him out
by himself why the [ __ ] are we even here
goodbye
yeah I'll buy you some time stop asking
for more time just you know like make it
a cliche thing I need more time and I
push this guy out of the way
Oh to use it's an anti-aircraft thing
you don't think it'd be useful anyway
okay so we guys just gonna protect I
guess oh they're coming up they're
coming up back here on the roof all
right looks like you're doing a great
job guys into that oh no I thought
what's down here you I fell on my bottle
you are get off your pot you lazy
student I got hit with bullets anybody
in the office cuz I like message to
everyone alive you kill those people all
take care of this giant bat sounds like
a good deal
stop shooting me
Wow
over here I'm gonna get you stop saying
that no one likes you
damn I'm getting mad
Oh Bucky stop
[Music]
[ __ ] off you old flood
yeah sweet let's get off that roof what
we have four seconds I know
I hope sweet oh my god I thought that
was five seconds oh my god do not do
this to me run right toward the red
diamond I'm assuming or no no sorry not
the red diamond v13 Peter are you
serious the blue marker over here why is
it below everything that's our base we
gotta go insane
oh no wait what we gotta go back into
this building is oh yeah go back come
back in the building we just left but
you gotta go into the base oh it's me
and Finn don't worry we got this here
isn't Finn
oh wait don't tell my knee every day
bring your child to work day we defend
[Music]
oh thank god you get points to good me
to put trash things it is your melees
chris is like a melee champion
jean-claude man yeah oh my god I have a
lot of
hand points yes
oh good okay yeah I don't have her
number
bear with me I'm still killing people
all right stop giving me points oh my
god can evil walk viewers are getting a
taste of how hectic every day I'm so
stressed out
died
good precious precious bullets
give me bullet
I need them
oh you [ __ ] dead
it's crazy
mo at least I'm getting a more because
I'm also night
let's go you're getting night
[Music]
yeah get night in your thing not a fine
did your bullet screaming so loud maybe
the bullet you're screaming so loud I
think I got I got read I got a for
coming
yeah but don't worry here's back
I feel like anyone who wants to show I'm
on this turn oh yeah we're gonna have a
thing
maybe I just don't have my earmuffs
blocking the sound of
maybe that was
coming
I am so ready to press that it looks so
cool
[Music]
did you get it
yeah I'm right next time I don't know I
don't know how to turn off that thing
again how do I turn off the thing yeah
anti-aircraft gun no it says my name
I'll come over here to Finn uh oh I see
press the left side of the touchpad
twice I think
all right next to Finn you're [ __ ]
getting shot [ __ ] getting messed up
like in a job office
- spins here yes what are we doing good
thing we have such cool Knievel fans cuz
what a mess I am today I'm this most
sober one in this room - it's true
it's Friday
oh thanks Robin
still found a way there was one behind
us this whole time
yeah called you a jackass oh I'm super
dead that's well I got I got my I got my
juice for the controller now you got
your juice for your liver now so we're
both set i got smooshed alright let's go
one more gun don't even worry about
jumping on let's go with bending to be
okay sprint
sniper okay that's got to kill me last
time so
boys a guy right next to where he is
going
jump down there we gotta come down last
night we got a fend finish Phineas and
Ferb
down you go dum-dum
Oh
what a shot they said it's doing it am I
going down this hole no over here off
the off the group I just over here
toward me in business
the zombie has killed look like Jake
hopefully wasn't okay did this yeah yeah
there's guys up on the roof I'm shooting
right now
then you are so
a lot of guys up in this house I know
and we can't get any other goddamn
Bullas been closed see get away from it
yeah you're good Bob give me bullets
another one so I think when you're
taking chair you're actually fighting
them if I remember correctly but I don't
think we're gonna do that campaign i
straight-up couldn't care less about
well you're almost a resonable seven I
think that's one most people on a watch
we can save Jake and sherry as a bonus
like Veronica whatever zero
Leon be campaign do what's that for get
out of here hey we just open the gate
oh there's a downward thing over here
they don't spiral like my life it's not
I'm actually doing really well lately
thank you for asking
oh this is why we couldn't get through
earlier
right we're figuring this
hey hey want nothing but your utmost
happiness Hey
prove it
those are bad guys
tonight I'm [ __ ] a absolute mess right
now
why's my l1 not telling you where to go
bro
that sniper almost got me come this way
hello
tear right back there I think oh yeah
we're just going back to how he came
where we came from you and your point
sherry it's not sure that's a zombie
sherry Birkin okay sweet let's uh get it
upstairs somewhere all right so what's
the plan we're just killing go go up the
ladder back in that building that should
be a good spot yeah we're just screwing
the stood out how the anti-air is gone
I'm going up with all 16 bullets I have
I shall kill them yeah
all right sec wait can I hear
who the [ __ ] are you there is there like
a little something above oh he's here
he's here Oh Fozzie squish you know that
that one I've been shooting in the mouth
there's a turret the other side you step
here I'm gonna go Jake and sherry are
here with you so I'm gonna go across
I'll you been shooting them off
I got em sure oh yeah shooting the mouth
and then when you stunt jumping but I
don't have enough like bullets to keep
this up okay well I'll
wait is he son
oh sure is now you might be coming back
for me
something we're not oh you got doesn't
roll in us that's her fault I overhear
you just give it some time oh I got it I
think he's funny on my side no but I got
no come on the turrets in the way yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah get up there that's
a quick time then if he's hugging it see
their circles or a sexy yeah
horsedick off you know it's on the back
alright so not to shoot that come down
here hey it's my team somewhere I shot
it was good okay I accidentally jump
back down oh he did
ding dong the witch is dead look at me
look at me quick take a photo are you I
don't know I just walked into the who's
that was hurting me thank you so much
for your help
hey hey I don't like you hang on oh you
jarheads all look the same to me pal
sorry
kidding me my mistake why was that
enough the anger appears is he always
this awesome
yeah we're crazy for letting him walk
away how many men have we lost a
mercenaries like him he's not our
problem
we can't lose sight of the BSA's mission
I mean in his defense they do look
similar to fight bioterrorism sir chef
Andy know what we're here for
rookie why'd you ask sweep that went
smooth actually it kind of more smoothly
than I thought I would yes my
controllers charging like Metal Gear
Solid 4 right now Wow way to be at the
head of the pack guys you think those
things are gonna experience spread out
like this does it here's a force hit hey
let me let me run it doesn't force me to
look around it forces me to hate the
game it's not working over here Pierce
Finn you're with me everyone else keeps
searching out here oh I found an emblem
oh wait hold on a second this is shaped
just like the Spencer mansion where are
you it's like as if yeah it's kinda like
Spencer mansion right like if this
little thing behind the staircase in the
middle Oh
city hall
I knifed it legit is that would be the
dining room door
oh is this modeled after the original
general size and structure kind of like
many rooms would be over there upstairs
there are doors but then there's like
this thing right here I have so little
ammo again hey piers piers over here
something saying piers like who could he
be talking about my peers are here my
peers here's some wealth
this is gruesome a brain with hood
butcher's knife in it and a colon and
they just splashes haddock right here
and then smear it across the wall over
here oh it's a trowel people get knifed
oh my got a shotgun Hey twelve rounds I
don't go by in like two seconds yeah I'm
just so glad to have I have a bunch of
grenades I should be using as well do I
have a lot of flash grenades I'm gonna
use those so something to consider
I don't it's kind of up to you cuz your
first time playing the game but a lot of
people have been hitting me up on
Twitter since we started like resonable
three asking if I could convince you to
play seven and VR technically it would
work yeah and it would just take a
little more setup before we record that
game will probably take you about 13 to
14 hours to beat so it might go over a
few weeks or add up obviously a bit
right that's the game we've been
building toward pretty much was the
original plan to play that ad release
I yes we're only like nine months behind
on I blinded him
I think shooting those shell parts don't
doesn't hurt any issues
yeah I don't think we're hurting him
right now let me throw a regular grenade
at him yeah I stunned him
oh yeah we're breaking off his shell a
little bit little he's charging
yeah these are the guys that drain your
ammo I remember these dudes well it's a
good thing we're playing a game where
they give you a [ __ ] ton of ammo
Heys that is ma'am over here ball for me
of these maybe points there yeah oh
there's another one oh [ __ ] don't worry
I got it
grenade foolish two of them
he's my last kanay time
Oh whoo
sniper rifle just got his armor off well
cube he might owe me Liam all right he
might have made me bad or sculling into
hell I blame you once you go into the
afterlife daddy like skull Hades
I almost said Ares search the rest of
the place but stay on your guard
shocking him over here for me I know
you're trying to help me but it sounds
selfish
Charcot a mo for me touch it
I know it's independent loot drop that's
still stay away from this area in
general lots of ammo for me all right
those all points for you yeah ha this is
Europe
didn't think about the guns did you hi
[Laughter]
throw me out like a taking a blanket
there is I have a plant in here I got
some plants - I don't know a man you got
tree 19 guns that I have I see mashing
that circle button bullets
what happened in here syringe I think
captain
these are button talk to gorillas who
are you two chimps I work here my name
is Ada Wong oh yeah I forget Chris
doesn't know us a virus that must be
what's creating this Jihlava yeah I
heard them saying something about that
what else did you hear
hey Jen mommy your guns down
not until you give us a reason to
Oh
keeps your boat umbrella she's so casual
about the way she hold her hands up
again with the gorillas what in the
Congo so the sea buyers came from them
that's all I know
thank you we appreciate your cooperation
Finn you're in charge of keeping her
safe yes sir don't you mean the other
way around
Jack she seems shady as [ __ ] we're gonna
see Leon and Elena soon remember the one
they were chasing when we were found one
of the sovereign Boyer now Leon and play
like no killer whatever vice versa we
start trying to kill her chase it down
so you can assume based on the brilliant
way this game Rasha balls everything
that she's gonna do something shitty to
us there's the plant we're gonna be
pissed for and also Finn was not with
them later on
so is this also the flashback come to
think of it or no I can't even remember
I don't know
[Music]
wait look at my screen I'm saying
something are you yeah I can hear you on
my screen
god I'm awesome which one's a second
okay let's actually I'm probably in a
way saying oh if we try to kill them
right now alright yeah you know you're
not nearly as cool as come back here the
store doesn't make sense in this mansion
it's just design no it's a co-op door
[ __ ] with who your friends are
oh my god was that
oh no but they're weak two knives a
shotgun
oh wait key all right hey vana hey
they're shooting it what are those
called
from Jurassic Park the one that kills
Newman correct no I don't think I can
open that door
that one's okay cool ADA make it happen
what door do we go okay there's been yep
hold on oh sweet actually bullets
Sardi's before they hatch they're so
gross
like the way they walk in
oh you little [ __ ] through his mucus
at me
burrows there was penises I was
impressed with that tuck and roll I just
did flashbang nice
yeah
oh this one's dead oho sniper rifles
they overpower this they're so
annoyingly fast dead
no dead
death by bullet
shoot a minute but stay down
see you shot to the slammer I look at
the new there's some ammo over here by
the next door all right come on 80
[Music]
oh she's gone the woman she had a name
friends
booby traps in it protect against
lizards thanks for the escort here's
something to remember me by
it's actually pretty gruesome
was so poisoning what was I doing most
peers like be an emo over in the corner
while Chris screen
works really fast that's what the C
virus stands for the quick photo
then vinegar battle we lose all right I
feel like I should be dead yeah
oh it's a concussion maybe a hairline
fracture
oh I thought you didn't Kris
Bend's a dick when he's drunk
we thought we saved that's not an ending
you know might call that an episode how
long was that
like 45 minutes that's weird
mm-hmm that entire area we're gonna call
that a night right now I can okay we're
getting closer to resonable 7:00 we're
gonna finish this campaign and I'm going
right to store as an evil 7 then we can
do more stuff afterwards because I'm
dying to play res evil 7 it's October
yeah I want to play the game that came
out in January
[Music]
that's crazy I know all right well thank
you guys for watching we're one step
closer to finishing this stupid game one
set by II wonder what the spoiler is
like